ก็
สวัสดีค่ะครูฟ้าสวัสดีค่ะครูหญิงสวัสดี
ค่ะนักเรียนพอดีค่ะนักเรียนไฟฟ้าวันนี้
วันอะไรคะ
วันนี้วันพุธค่ะวันที่เท่าไหร่คะวันที่
22 เดือนอะไรคะเดือน
มิถุนายน
ปีพตอะไรคะปีพต 2  5  6 ห้าปีคศอะไรคะ
ปีคศ 2  022 ค่ะเมื่อวานนี้วันอะไรคะ
เมื่อวานนี้วันอังคาร
วันที่เท่าไหร่คะ
วันที่ 23  21
อาเบะเดือนเดือน
มิถุนายนปีพตตปีพ.ศ
2565 ปีคศ
ปีค.ศ
2022 ค่ะพรุ่งนี้วันอะไรคะพรุ่งนี้วัน
พฤหัสบดีวันที่เท่าไหร่คะวันที่
23 เดือน
เดือน
มิถุนายนปีพตตปีพต 2  5  6 ห้าปีคศมีข้อ
2022 หากค่ะตอนนี้เวลากี่โมงคะครูฟ้า
ตอนนี้เวลา
12:00 นที่แห้งกี่นาที
25 วินาทีอีกทีค่ะครูหญิงเลีย 15 นาที
ก็เป็นตอนกลางวันไฉนคนสัน
กินข้าวหรือยังคะไม่ใช่อยู่บ้านกินข้าว
หรือยังคะ
คือฟ้ากินข้าวแล้วค่ะกินข้าวกินทำเบอเก้อ
กูฟ้ากินแฮมเบอร์เกอร์นี้ทำเบอเก้อนะคะ
นักเรียน
กินแฮมมึง
ใช้หากผู้หญิงล่ะผู้หญิงกินข้าวหรือยัง
ผู้หญิงกินข้าวแล้วกินอะไร
ครูหญิงกินส้มตำ
ส้มตำนะคะนักเรียนแป๊บนึงนะ
อะไรว่าคิวฟ้า
คือปลาเนี่ยกูภายใน in  Thailand นะคะอ่ะ
หมอเขาอยู่ประเทศไทย
ลูกค้าอยู่ประเทศไทยนี่ประเทศไทยแล้ว
เนี่ยอะไรมือสวยผู้หญิงได้อยู่อเมริกา
ผู้หญิงอยู่อเมริกากินส้มตำคู่ฟ้าอยู่
ประเทศไทยกินแฮมเบอร์เกอร์
สำหรับแก๊สแรง
คุณครูทำไมแปลกๆ
ผู้หญิงอยู่ประเทศไทยก็แบบก็อยากกินอยาก
กินส้มตำแต่ส้มตำเนี่ยมีพริก
ใช่ไหมพริก Map
เผ็ด
อีกแบตส้มตำผู้หญิงกินส้มตำวันนี้นะครับ
กูป่า
ส้มตำปูรู้ไม่เห็น
เธอกินส้มตำปูเนี่ยกินเสร็จประมาณ 3  20
นาที
ปวดท้องผู้หญิง
ส่วน
ห้องน้ำห้องน้ำไปห้องน้ำใช่ห้องน้ำ
ห้องน้ำห้องน้ำสมัยปวดท้องเพราะว่าส้มตำ
ตัวเนี่ยบางครั้งเนี่ยกินแล้วแบบท้องไม่
โอเคคือผู้หญิงก็วิ่ง
น้ำอเมริกาเนี่ยไม่เหมือนประเทศไทยณ
ประเทศไทยเนี่ยห้องน้ำห้องน้ำมากๆ
ใช่ทำไมอ่ะอเมริกาไม่มีห้องน้ำเหรอคะมีมี
แต่ว่าห้องน้ำก็จะเป็นร้านงานไงถ้าครู
หญิงเนี่ยไม่ได้กินอาหารที่ร้าน
ก็จะเดินในห้องขอโทษนะคะเข้าห้องน้ำมา
เปิดสขอให้ไง
อ่านว่าปวดท้องและผู้หญิงปวดท้องปวดท้อง
ปวดท้องเพื่อจะทำยังไงคะเราก็ต้องแต่โชค
ดีไงครูฟ้าผู้หญิงเนี่ยยังอยู่ที่ร้านส้ม
ตำกินเสร็จได้เหมือนก็
ยังอยู่ที่ร้านพอปวดท้องก็เลยวิ่งเข้า
ห้องน้ำ
สบายใช่ไหมแต่งห้องน้ำที่อเมริกาเนี่ยนะ
คะเขาไม่มีอันนี้ไงไม่ใช่งูนะคะ
ไม่มีถามห้องน้ำไปให้ไทยมีงูด้วยนะนี่ไง
ห้องน้ำที่ประเทศไทยเนี่ยจะมี
มีสายฉีดใช่ไหมสายฉีดห้องน้ำที่อเมริกา
เนี่ยไม่มีเอ้ายังไงอ่ะ
ก็เขาจะมีเป็นทิชชู่
สวิทซ์ชุบใช่ไหมนิดชู่กระดาษทิชชู่ชายก็
มีกระดาษทิชชู่
ไม่ชอบเลยอะไรนะคะไม่ชอบเลยอ่ะต้องใช่
ทรายใส่คนไทยต้องมีน้ำด้วยนะใช่ค่ะนั่น
แหละก็ปวดท้องเข้าห้องน้ำใช่ไหมพ่อปวด
ท้องเข้าห้องน้ำแล้วเนี่ยอุ้ยก็เลยคิด
มีคำถาม
สนุกๆมาถามครูฟ้าเกี่ยวกับปวดท้องเข้า
ห้องน้ำ
ครูหญิงรฐามครูฟาว่าอะไรคะเอ้าเพราะว่า 1
วันใช่ไหมคะ 1 วันเนี่ยครูฟ้าอาจจะกิน
อาหารอะไรแบบไม่โอเคแล้ว
ปวดท้องมากๆสมัยมวนท้องมากๆแล้วก็
แต่กูขาก็ปวดท้องเลยฟ้าก็คิดอยากวิ่งเข้า
ห้องน้ำ
หรือเปล่าเวลาที่เราปวดท้องอ่ะแต่ปวดท้อง
แบบกดโอ้ยไม่ไหวแล้วไม่ไหวแล้วเราก็ไม่สน
ใจอะไรใช่ไหมเราก็คิดให้น้ำห้องน้ำและ
ห้องน้ำนี่ล่ะที่เป็นซักโครกนะคะนักเรียน
ห้องน้ำกินน้ำน้ำห้องน้ำกองภูฟ้าเนี่ยเจอ
ห้องน้ำ
ห้องน้ำก๊อกวิ่งยิงเข้าไปในห้องน้ำแล้วก็
นั่งแล้วก็นั่ง
แล้วก็น่าก็
สบายนักเรียนทั้งชุดก็วันนี้กินข้าวไม่
ได้นะคะ
ห้องน้ำแล้วก็สิทธิ์
ผู้ฟ้าต้องหานะก็ต้องหาทิชชู่ใช่ไหมทิชชู
สำหรับเช็ดทำความสะอาด
ถ้ามาก็หาทิชชู่
สายฉีดเนี่ยประเทศไทยมีสายฉีดใช่ไหมใช่
เพื่อใครจะมีสายฉีดที่เป็นน้ำจ่ายสายฉีด
ในห้องน้ำนี้เนี่ยไม่มีไม่มีสายฉี่
แล้วโทรฟ้าก็สายฉีดไม่มี
คนไทยทำให้สบายใจแล้วนะกูบาดะห์หาทิชชู่
ใช่ไหมคะเห็นชู้
ทิชชู่ mon
นักเรียนอาจจะคิดไม่รู้ว่าประเทศที่
อเมริกาเนี่ยผู้หญิงยังไม่เคยเจอห้องน้ำ
ที่
ทิชชู่หมดเพราะว่าบางครั้งเนี่ยเขาก็จะมี
ทิชชู่อยู่ที่นี่คิดชั่วอยู่ที่นี่หมด
ยิ้มได้แต่ประเทศไทยเนี่ยบางครั้งเราเจอ
เข้าห้องน้ำแล้วทิสชู่หมดเหรียญพระครูฟ้า
ปวดท้องแบบโอ๊ยปวดท้องปวดท้องอืดแล้วนะ
อ้าไม่ใช่เธอ
เขตกี่วันทั้งนั้นเมื่อทู
แล้วแล้ว
มีทิชชู่
ครูฟ้า
จะทำยังไง
รวมปากคิดว่าครูฟ้าจะทำยังไงกูมานั่งแล้ว
เสร็จแล้วแต่ทิชชู่ไม่มี
สีฟ้าว่าครูฟานาจะ
1ปีหลายๆวิธีเหรอคะใช่คิดไว้นะคะหนึ่งกู
ไปคิดว่ากูฟ้าต้องมีโทรศัพท์ใช่ไหม
คะก็มีกระเป๋าปกติของกูฟ้านั่นแหละเราก็
จะมี
เซรั่ม
หน้าจะโทรหาเพื่อนฮัลโหล
ฮัลโหล
ไม่มีทิชชูในห้องน้ำ
ก็มีทิชชู่หรอไม่มี
เอาขอหน่อยขอขอให้ให้เราเอาทิชชูไปให้ฟ้า
หรอเธอเคยเอาทิชชูมาให้ที่ห้องน้ำฟ้าอยู่
ห้องอะไรเออ
501 ที่ห้องน้ำหรือเปล่า
ผู้ชายหนาว่าน้องน่ะอ่าเดินเข้ามาในห้อง
น้ำเดินมาแล้วอยู่ห้องที่อี้ 3 ตอนที่ 3
ข้างขวาข้างซ้าย
ซ้ายหรือขวาป้องที่ 3 ห้องที่ 3 ข้างขวา
โอเค
ฮะโอเคแล้วก็ขี่ก็เดินเอาไปแล้วก็สอดช่าง
ล่างใช่มั้ยห้องน้ำมันจะมีแบบข้างหน้ารี่
ประตูตรงนี้เนาะหนูจะมีพื้นที่ 21 ที่
ว่างๆผิดฟ้าขอบคุณมากเลยก็ได้คิดชู้มามา
ใช่ไหมนี้หนึ่งนะคะ
มา
2 อุบะ
ครูบาอัดจะ
ได้แล้วก็เองว่าจะทำอะไร
อันนี้ก็จะเป็นห้องสมุด 2 ครูฟ้าเนี่ยไม่
มีโทรศัพท์
ไม่มีโทรศัพท์
กูคิดว่ากูฟ้าก็ต้องมี
คน
ข้าง
ห้องข้างๆอ่ะอ่าสมัยนักเรียน
[เพลง]
อ้าวกดผิด
ห้องข้างๆข้างซ้าย
แล้วก็จะตกๆอะไรคะคืออือมีกระดาษทิชชู่
ไหมคะพอดีว่ากระดาษทิชชู่ห้องของเราห้อง
ของดิฉันนห้องของฉันห้องของเราเนี้ย
ไฟฟ้านะเราคุยคนอื่นไงกระดาษทิชชู่มันหมด
อ๋อไม่มีหรอไม่มีกระดาษทิชชู่ค่ะขอหน่อย
ได้ไหม
โอเคเดี๋ยวดูก่อนนะคะอีกก็หาอ๋อขอโทษนะคะ
ห้องของเราไม่มี
กระทิชชูเหมือนกัน
ถ้าอย่างนั้นเราก็อยู่เป็นเพื่อนกันมี
ร้านนึงอ๋ออ๋อข้างขวาตกๆสวัสดีครับเอาไม่
ได้หรอ
กูทำอะไรกูมาเรียน City สวัสดีค่ะช้างคือ
กระดาษทิชชู่ห้องของเราหมดค่ะขอกระดาษ
ทิชชูหน่อยได้ไหมคะเดี๋ยวสักครู่นะคะเป็น
ก็เพราะคุณที่เรามี
ฝนมนๆ
อ่ะนี่ค่าขอบคุณค่ะคือทั้งหมดนั่งได้กี่
คนพอไหมคะ
ขอ 1 ม้วนได้ไหมคะ
นี่มีม้วนที่เราค่ะมีม้วนเดียว
ขออีกค่ะขออีกยังไม่พอ
อุ้ยดีชาขอบคุณค่ะ
จะเอากระดาษทิชชูให้ห้องข้างๆพี่ไม่มี
เหมือนกัน
อันนี้ก็
รู้หนาวอะไรก็ได้ดีชั่วหมดก็จะขอห้องข้าง
ๆใช่ไหมนี้นักเรียนมือครูฟ้าแล้วถ้าครู
ฟ้าเนี่ยไม่มีโทรศัพท์
ห้องช่างๆไม่มีคนทั้งห้องน้ำเนี่ยมีครู
ฟ้าอยู่คนเดียวทิชชู่ไม่มีแค่ได้ชูไม่มี
ครูฟ้าจะทำยังไงกูมากรี๊ดได้มั้ย
แต่ห้องฉันช่างเนี่ยห้องข้างๆเนี่ยไม่มี
นะคนไม่มีนะ
ไม่มีคนทำยังไงมีครูฟ้าคนเดียวในห้องน้ำ
น้ำตกอ้าย 9 กับผิดขอโทษนะคะ
ไม่ต้องกอล์ฟก็ได้นะดูขาก็ได้ใช่ไหมไม่มี
คนให้ไม่มีคน
บ่นแล้วมีคนในห้องน้ำไหมคะ
ก็ไม่มีคน
ขอกลัวมากนะเอ๊ย
ฟ้าเธอทำยังไงจัดใช้อะไรทำความสะอาดแทน
ผู้ชายช่วยปี่เอ้ากูบ้าเคยเห็นในหนัง
ฝรั่งในผู้หญิงทำยังไงหนังฝรั่งใช่มั้ย
นักเรียนแบบหนังประเทศยุโรปอะไรงั้นหรือ
ว่าหนังฮอลลีวู้ดเขาก็ต้องมีถุงเท้าไง
แล้วนักเรียนก็จะหมด
ครูฟ้าอ่ะมีถุงเท้าไหมร้องไห้ใส่ถุงเท้า
ไม่ม้าถุงเท้ากูฝากก็ไม่ใส่ทิชชู่หมดห้อง
ข้างๆไม่มีคน
โทรศัพท์ครูฟ้าก็ไม่ได้เอามา
กุมภาทำยังไงอ่ะกูก็จะนั่งรอคนมาค่ะ
อย่างนี้มันจะนั่งอยู่แบบนี้เลยนั่งแล้ว
ก็ได้ได้ยินเสียง
กรุบๆมีคนฮ้างมีคนเดินเดินเดินมา
ไม่มีมีคนน่ะ
ฟ้าเนี่ยได้ยินเสียงมีคนเดินต้องแตก
ต๊อกแต๊กตกๆๆๆๆๆๆ
ขอโทษนะคะ
แล้วนะคะมีคนอยู่ไหมคะมีคนอยู่ไหมก็ดีค่ะ
มีอะไรคะ
คือกระดาษทิชชู่หมดค่ะขอกระดาษทิชชูหน่อย
ได้ไหมอ๋อและได้ๆค่ะเดี๋ยวดูว่ามีห้องไหน
รอสักครู่นะคะไหนก็ได้ค่ะเดี๋ยวก็หยิบอ่ะ
นี่ค่ะได้แล้วค่ะกระดาษทิชชู่คุณค่ะขาว
ขอบคุณมากค่ะฟ้าท่านั่งรอ 1 ชั่วโมงก็รอ
ต้องรอค่ะทำอะไรไม่ได้
รอเท่านั้นฟ้าไม่มีถุงเท้าผ้าฉันน่ารัก
ไหมมาสินะไม่มีภูเขาไม่ใช้คิดว่า
ได้มั้ยได้ไม่มีเสื้อใส่ออกมาไงมันก็เดิน
แบบว่าไม่ใส่เสื้ออย่างนี้หรอเออ
นี่ล่ะค่ะก็เป็นกินขาวสนุกสนุกๆ
ทั้งหมดแล้วหมดและหมดแล้วใช่ไหม
ไม่รู้เหมือนกันนะฮะก็เป็นคำถามสนุกๆนะ
ทารุแล้วถ้าเป็นนักเรียนราคะนักเรียน
เนี่ยมาขับไปเข้าห้องน้ำปวดท้องนะปวดท้อง
เข้าห้องน้ำแล้ว
ห้องน้ำกระดาษทิชชูเนี่ยหมดไม่มีจะดาษ
ทิชชู
นักเรียนจะทำยังไง
ได้นักเรียนก็คอมเม้นท์บอกครูนักเรียนไม่
มีโทรศัพท์นะมีโทรศัพท์นะ
คอพิมพ์ค้าง
ไม่มีคนมีนักเรียนอยู่คนเดียวในห้องน้ำ
แล้วก็กระดาษทิชชู่หมด
นักเรียนจะทำยังไงจะนั่งรอเหมือนครูฟ้า
ไหมนะคะนั่นก็คอมเม้นท์บอกเราได้เนาะแต่
ดูวีดีโอนี้เนี่ยเดี๋ยวเราสองคนไปก่อนนะ
คะได้หาเราเจอกันใหม่วิดีโอหน้านะคะนัก
เรียนวันนี้ก็สวัสดีค่ะอ่ะ
[เพลง]